- Yes Phil?
My hat size?
No I do not know my hat size.
I don't wear hats.
(muttering)
I wear beanies.
- [Phil] You wear that Yankees.
- I do wear hats a little bit
when I beat you in tennis.
You've never beaten me, bam.
What are you doing?
- [Man] Measuring your
head, it's for your hat.
This is absurd.
(upbeat, energetic music)
You have to communicate
contextually and creatively
in these channels where
these humans now live.
I love how people keep
saying this is coming.
I always get such a kick out of that
because this, it's happened.
The data is so black and white,
there's a reason 97% of
consumer packaged goods
are declining.
It's 'cause they're over
allocating in trade, FSI's,
television, direct mail.
It's just so black print.
It's just so black and white.
I almost feel like I'm in
that movie, the Big Short,
and I'm the guy with the glass eye.
The fundamentals are obvious.
Yeah, what up Instagram.
We're about to draw, thank you so much.
When did we do it, Cyber Monday?
Black Friday, Tuesday, Saturday?
Anyway, doing the drawing,
five of you are gonna join
me for dinner in New York.
What's gonna happen?
Alex is gonna get all the winners
and then coordinate with all five
and we can send it all the
way out to like, April?
Am I flying them out here?
Yeah I did, yeah.
Flying out the five of you
to New York for dinner.
Now, for everybody who doesn't know
what the fuck is going on,
on Black Friday weekend,
Cyber Monday weekend,
I did a giveaway.
Give me Crushing It real quick.
I'm gonna do another one right now, right?
So we're gonna do a
breakfast version of this.
This is the dinner version,
I'll get to it in a minute.
Where do we send the receipts to?
Okay, we're gonna start a new one
called 10copies@vaynermedia.com.
Andy, can you have somebody set
up 10copies@vaynermedia.com?
- [Andy] Ten copies?
- You got that D-rock?
D-rock can do things like that?
D-rock, good shit.
Anyway, get ready for
everyone who's watching.
10copies@vaynermedia.com.
You weren't part of the five,
it costs you less to do the
dinner than the breakfast.
That's how shit works.
Wait till lunch at
40copies@vaynermedia.com.
But right now, five
copies if you bought it,
so for example, this
person's gonna be sad.
I'm gonna pull this one right now.
You did not win, this is gonna
be a heartbreaking moment.
But this person, for example, Bill James,
he could've won but he didn't.
He did not win.
But Phil bought five copies
and so he got in here once
but other people bought 10 copies,
and Lev, over here, Lev, did his job.
He's not only good at
finding Darren Lee jerseys,
he's also good at, if
you bought 20 copies,
four of your receipts came in here.
Five of you are getting flown out
to have dinner with me together.
Can't wait to do it.
It's gonna be a great podcast.
It's gonna be a great piece of content.
And all of you will be buying Crushing It,
all of you, all of Earth.
I'm gonna pull out five people right now
And the five, Phil James, I'm sorry.
The first person joining me for dinner
in New York somewhere in the spring
is, I'm just gonna give these
to you right on the spot,
(verbal drum roll)
You're just filming, you're
not part of the content, Tyler.
Here we go, is, is,
can you help me here?
You don't have the name?
Like what, is that why you wrote that?
- [Lev] Yeah, Canner.
- Yeah, but what's the
person's first name?
- [Lev] That was the
first name of the email.
Hold on.
- Show him, he's a real bad guy.
He's probably getting fired.
Guys, breaking news, Lev's been fired.
Let's just send him right to HR.
All right, I've got news
for you, it's in the UK.
Oh, it got chopped off.
Not your fault.
Lev, congratulations.
Canner in the UK.
You're the first.
Fucking UK, right off the bat.
These next four better be in London
so we can just do it in London.
Canner congrats.
Person number two, now remember
for all of you that are live,
sorry for people, we'll
have to edit a little bit.
Nah, actually just leave it.
Five copies on one day,
you send in the receipts
to 5copies@vaynermedia.com,
now I'm pulling it.
Dinner with me probably in New York,
but maybe now London.
And we're about to do
another one in a second,
you guys did not miss out no FOMO
if you wanna have breakfast
with me and five others,
it's gonna be 10 copies,
this is gonna keep going up.
Breakfast, oh, afternoon tea, right,
is gonna be like 80 copies.
Number two is David Hutchinson
in San Bernardino, California.
We're off to a tough start location wise.
Person number three to
have dinner with me,
it's gonna be epic too.
I'm gonna teach you everything about life
and make you 43 million dollars.
That's a good trade for five copies.
D-rock have you set up
10copies@vaynermedia.com?
Third person for this one is Eric Algern
in San Diego, California.
All right, two in California right now.
Person number four, I got it.
It's Jarn Shoden-Pirabon, congratulations.
I've no idea where you're from,
but it looks like it's in US dollars.
Let's hope.
And the final person in
the first dinner series,
breakfast series coming up
next, is C. Helth Hipple.
Congratulations to the five
winners and that's that.
Let's pick one person who
would have been a winner
if I was doing six people
just for a little razz.
Just so you can make the
joke with your friends.
The first person that
lost is Levi McCormick.
Sorry Levi.
Hey everybody this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and this is episode 376
of the AskGaryVee show.
This is the Friday before Christmas
so the office is in that perfect zone.
I love the fact that so many
of you are traveling right now
and you're at home, out of
office replies, that scale
is always when I'm most comfortable
because when the world is not working
I am actually calm.
It evolved different
than our conversations
we really thought, and
we still will do this,
we want to activate for a lot of clients.
A lot of clients spend too much money,
no different than
commercials and banner ads.
You know we're always
looking for where's money
being overspent in the reality
of the world we live in.
We feel a lot of clients, the
biggest brands in the world,
when they're at Superbowl,
when they're at the MBA finals
and all-star weekend and
the Kentucky Derby and CES,
spend a lot of money to
do boots or mail-in things
that we think there's an
opportunity to do better.
We specially think that
there's something incredible
around the culture of activating
that is Instagram worthy
and how digital and social
work with real life.
But we thought that that's
what was gonna be the core
and that we would sprinkle ads sometime.
Wouldn't it be cool if
we created our own thing
whether it's a South by
Southwest or a Coachella
and obviously I'm using the biggest of big
but we'll do our own things.
But in true Gary and Kim fashion
like in four seconds we're like,
"You know, let's launch
our own conference."
And that's how agent
2021, how did agent 2021,
how was that actually born?
I mean that was the theory
but what did happen?
Did I like text you in
the middle of the night?
- Erm, probably.
Yeah, or it was just an emoji.
Maybe just like a little
arrow sign like a car.
- Like a smiley face with
dollar signs coming out of it.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
No I think like with
Vayner Media as a whole
and you, obviously, have had
a ton of inbound requests
just in terms of these four industries.
There's a huge gap between
how they're marketing
their businesses and where
consumer attention is.
- The four industries are travel agents,
insurance agents, car dealerships,
and real estate agents.
(fast-paced, upbeat music)
When you get a chance to
tell me how great you are
or it is, or that is, you
need somebody's attention.
What eliminates the real
estate agents of the moment,
their lack of innovation.
You DM the person and say,
"I own a car dealership.
"I'd like to pay you to
show up at my car dealership
"this Saturday from 12 to 4 and you tell
"your Instagram followers."
I had somebody who's done
over a million dollars
in revenue in the insurance space
doing only content and
advertising only through Facebook.
Every hotel company
should've gotten together
and then bought residential
and then created an Airbnb competitor.
The startup tech world now
reminds me a lot of real estate
now that I've been in it
because the real estate industry
has cycles when it's so
good that losers win.
I think it's a really good
idea for every dealership here
to buy the 20,000 mile
radius around the four
closest high schools to your dealership.
(fast-paced rock music)
Kim, I love you.
- I love you too.
- All right, everybody have
a great, great, great holiday
season, I hope you enjoy this episode.
I hope we see a bunch of you in Miami
hit up K-pop and @vaynerexperience
if you've got questions
they've been incredible on that.
And we will see you, you
keep asking questions,
we will keep answering them.
What happened?
How did you find my stuff?
Somewhere on Instagram?
- So, I started looking around
and when I saw your stuff,
you talking about you
don't do it for the money,
you do it because you wanna
give, serving the people.
And that's the most beautiful thing.
'Cause I think that's
where you can get legacy.
- Legacy.
- And leave something behind.
- Men in their '20's they're
in their most insecure
state, looking to scratch
a lot of short term itches,
and at the end of the bad habits
and I didn't even have my twenties.
I worked in my Dad's
liquor store day and night,
I did nothing.
I did more fun stuff last night
by going to the Knicks game.
- I was there as well.
- Yeah, you went too?
- Oh yeah.
- [Man] It was good when
the Garden's buzzing.
- Yeah, it's fun when
So you're super excited
about the World Cup?
- Super excited.
There's so much things coming up.
And as a striker things can go quickly.
So, how do you influence the culture
in the way, like as a supporter.
- You have to do one thing.
Just speak your truth.
You know this.
Instagram is the place, right?
Instagram is the place.
So when I look at your Instagram, right?
You have such an interesting mix.
Like that father son thing, that's smart.
So for example, let's just
look at the difference
between my account and your account.
You'll find this interesting.
These are subtle things that
I don't talk about a lot.
He's happy right now.
Look, here's my profile.
It's got four long lines of data,
it's got this new Instagram
stories, the highlights
you can put it in there,
where I can really tell my story, right?
- [Man] Yeah, you've
scored in the World Cup.
- That clip should be right
here in my World Cup goal right?
Whereas in your account,
God is my guide is amazing,
but you've four more lines,
it's only linked to your Twitter.
Little things, like it's not
bragging when it's a truth.
How old were you when you
scored your World Cup goal?
- 19.
- You know, it might be
something interesting.
I do like the fact that you've got the mix
of the football content and
the personal content, right?
I do think that's good,
but I also think a little
less polish, right?
So, I think the biggest thing
celebrities in their space
need to do is have, once in
a while, just really raw.
Everybody wants their
Instagram to look so perfect.
You've just said, smartly,
the kids of my generation
we're not sharing our problems
because everybody's living
a P.R.'ed life on Instagram.
If you look at people's
lives on Instagram,
everybody's P-Diddy.
I think one of the things that
has been really strong for me
is I don't need my content to be polished.
Some of it is, some of it isn't,
biggest lesson for these guys right?
They wanna make great content.
Great content is the
truth, not the lighting.
If you're such a thoughtful young man,
I'm getting that sense so quickly,
when you have a thought,
just going in to the camera
and just saying, "Hey
everybody, this is my thought."
Especially with the story you just told me
would be amazing that second day
when you're down in that league,
now you've got time to think.
I used to say lots of smart shit like,
"Good content is the
truth, not the lighting."
It was lost in space, but
now Babin's super excited
'cause he's gonna make
that one minute video,
you know what I mean?
To me, here's something that
I think is always powerful
about athletes.
That classic Nike like commercial
where it's like you guys
see me scoring a goal
in the World Cup when I'm 19,
but you're not seeing me the
day after I got injured, right?
Like you see it went fast, for me.
- You don't see the...
- I think that's why what
I'm doing is so powerful.
I'm documenting the journey.
- Everything.
- And everything changed
when I started the vlog
two years ago, because all
of a sudden when I would talk
about hustle and hard work,
it's so obvious in their face.
Look what today is, you
know, it's three days
before Christmas, the city's shut down,
but who's in my office?
My team.
That's just the truth, and
by the way, I don't think
this is right, I'm thrilled
that 95% of my company
is with their family right
now, and they should be.
And I can't wait, a couple
more hours and pfft,
next two weeks I'm out.
But, the truth is the truth
is the truth is the truth.
I think I'm very excited because I think
we're going through a phase right now
where everybody's trying to show the best,
but we've always done that.
Your grandparents in Kenya,
when they went outside,
something bad was happening in the house,
but when they went
outside and had a coffee,
nine out of ten times.
- Good.
- I hate when people are
like, "Social media's..."
I keep saying it's exposing us,
Oh, now people are learning
that we always put up facades
and we don't have real conversations.
But we were doing that for years.
When all the old Russian men used to go
and play checkers outside in Russia,
maybe if they drank a coupla vodkas
they'd share on what's going on at home,
but like most people,
especially immigrants, you know.
What happens in the house right?
(mumbles)
- Hundred per cent man.
In my household, every single bad thing
that happened in my family
that I saw with my eyes
and I can remember from 6-18,
died in those fucking four walls.
You went outside there's a (clicking).
So when people are like,
"Oh everybody shows the
best version of themselves,
"we're P.R.'ing, we're not sharing."
We never fucking shared.
You understand?
So if you have the ability
and the power to share
well then you owe it.
- You need to know yourself.
- That's right and you're young.
Listen, I'll tell you right now,
and this is what I always want to say.
I'm glad you've said that
because it allows me to say
to the vlog.
I have the benefit of the
internet coming around
when I was already a man.
Now there's a lot of me that
wishes this was happening
when I was 22 'cause I fucking....
It would've been amazing to do a vlog
that looked the same
every day for nine years,
me in a liquor store.
For 15 fucking hours a day.
'Cause then everybody
would be like, "Whoa."
I love it when people
are like, "oh, duh duh."
I'm like, "Go on YouTube
and look at episode one
"of Wine Library TV to a thousand."
There's a thousand wine videos
'cause that's what business I grew up in,
where you can see nobody was watching.
So, it's cool man.
That makes me happy that
you wanna share like that.
You should, but don't be fancy.
- Don't be fancy.
- And if you need to use
Snapchat and Instagram stories,
'cause that's what people are doing,
they're willing to be less fancy there.
Everybody's put the
Instagram feed on a pedestal,
mistake.
I love aesthetics, I
understand design, mistake.
You know how many people didn't post today
'cause they have a pimple?
(laughing)
- A lot, but that's our
generation, you know.
- No, no, I've got good news for you.
That was my generation too.
- Was it?
- A hundred per cent.
People are shitting on
millennials as if they did it.
20 years ago none of us posted
shit without a zit either.
If we just didn't have it.
So we didn't go out
that Friday night, lost.
Got it?
It's just documented now.
That's all, nothing's changed.
Here's the thing, every
young person on this earth
needs to become grateful.
No matter how bad their situation is
because they have the power of this
to get them the fuck out.
That's fucking huge.
- That's big.
- It's bigger than big.
I get emails, Tyler will
tell you, he's my MX ,
from homeless people because
they've got smartphones.
So when I hear some fucking kid who's sad
I'm like, hanging out and having a chat.
I'm like dude, you
haven't even any context
of what's going on in the
world, and you know this,
a great advantage you
have is your heritage,
coming from where you came from.
Your family came from a big city in Kenya?
- No they came from, yeah
they come from a big city
but they didn't have
no doubt difficulties.
- Hell of a lot different than Paris.
I've gotten really, not full circle,
but the fact that when I came
to America we lived in Queens,
and not the Queens that it is now.
In a fucking room, the size
of this fucking office.
Multiple family members,
the fact that I know that
and remember it, oof.
- It makes you tough.
- I'm so much tougher than everybody.
Like, I can go to zero again.
- Absolutely.
(laughing)
- When you can go to zero
again, that's why I'm dangerous,
I can go to zero again.
- You have nothing to lose.
- Nothing.
- That's something I'm
starting to have now
'cause I'm not doing it for the money.
I saw all the cars and everything
but, the thing that's
gonna push me to the end
and make you a legend
and influence this world
is not the things that we see now.
- A hundred per cent.
- Having a family, stable
family, next to you
and wanting the right things
and that just changed my whole perspective
'cause now I meet people and ...
- My man, my man, you're 22
years old talking like this.
You are so blessed.
You know how hard it is.
These two jerk offs don't know it yet.
(laughing)
They know it more, he's very smart.
Listen I know them cold, right,
they know it a lot more
than they did before,
but not all the way yet.
You can't, they haven't
been as lucky as you
and may be they didn't get
it out of their system yet.
Tyler, definitely not.
You know, like the bottom
line is, it's a big deal.
It's such an interesting observation.
I sit here and say I've
got nothing to lose
and the person watching
on YouTube right now
is like, "What the
fuck's he talking about?
"He has so much stuff."
I have nothing to lose 'cause the stuff
is not what I'm playing for.
- And that's massive, yeah.
- It's huge, there's people
who wanna buy a Viper
or a Rolex or like cool sneakers.
I don't wanna buy sneakers,
I wanna buy sneaker companies
with them and win Super Bowls.
And I don't even want that, I
just want the chance to do it.
The game.
Anyway man, you're a good dude.
- Thanks man.
Nice to meet you, man.
- Really nice to meet you.
Let's stay in touch, take a famous photo
and get our Instagram's up.
- Let's do it.
- I love the home and home.
Happy hug man, real pleasure.
Bye guys.
Bye D-Rock I miss you.
I don't even remember you any more.
Here, we're good.
Hold one second guys,
hold on, hold on a second.
See ya vlog, in 2018.
(slow, electronic music)